[MUSIC PLAYING]
NIR TARCIC: Hi, everyone.
I'm Nir Tarcic.
I'm a site reliability
engineer for Waze.
Picking a cloud provider
is not an easy task.
And there is a perception that
the cost of switching providers
is high.
I'm here to show you
it's not always the case,
and switching cloud
providers is a doable task
with the right set of tools,
procedures, and measures.
For example, we migrated
large portions of our system
from AWS into GCP in
just a matter of months,
with just a team of two people.
How many of you use Waze today?
Raise your hands.
Wow, OK.
Thank you.
Awesome.
For those of you who are
not familiar with Waze,
we provide
turn-by-turn navigation
with real-time traffic data.
We currently have over
80 million active users,
with an average usage of
582 minutes every month.
That's a lot of traffic jam.
I really love working for Waze.
I think it has an amazing
culture for engineering.
It's so incredible to
work on a product that
helps a lot of people
on a daily basis.
Let's watch a quick clip on
what Waze does for its users.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- When Waze first
launched, its core
was about outsmarting
traffic together.
CCP is the next natural
evolution of Waze.
Now, we're really
talking about saving time
for millions of people.
- Our drivers are out on
the streets every hour
of every day, reporting the
most accurate information
on closures and congestion.
We are taking that
information and delivering it
to the government officials
who can address incidents
in real time.
- This is a real program
with real impact.
We're actually sitting
down with partners
and having measurable
results every day.
- Boston is a city of
around 600,000 residents.
But during a
typical work day, we
grow to over a million people.
Waze has allowed us to rapidly
iterate through experiments
to see what sort of
effect interventions
have on congestion and traffic.
- We had a major
snow last March.
Seeing the data come in
from Waze every 2 minutes
allows us to grab
user reports and then
we can respond to those
reports in a timely manner.
- Genesis is a software
company that provides solutions
to help first responders.
By putting Waze inside
our Genesis PULSE product,
our first responders
are saving 5 minutes,
and that saves lives.
- We didn't expect
that so quickly we
would have cities redistributing
traffic personnel,
that we would have 911
systems relying on this data.
- As more data
comes online, Waze
is proud to bring together
innovative transportation
leaders from all
around the world
to develop the next chapter
in traffic management.
- At the core, CCP
has the same mission
as Waze, which is to save
people time every day.
It's showing us
what our new goals
are going to be-- new forms
of safety and new forms
of urban mobility--
helping cities become
a lab for making lives better.
[END PLAYBACK]
NIR TARCIC: All right.
So now that we understand
what we do in order
to improve everyone's
lives, let's take a second
and look at our scale.
What does it take
to power up Waze
to serve over 80 million users?
Lets start with the basics.
Each front-end serving stack
is behind a low bouncer
and has auto-scaling enabled
to shrink and grow as needed.
That way, we allow ourselves to
have the flexibility in terms
of rush hour, or save costs when
it's the middle of the night
and no one is driving.
On the database side,
we use Cassandra.
We have over 800
nodes of Cassandra.
Each cluster also contains
a Memcached site cluster.
That Memcached is used to store
temporary data or Cassandra
data.
Because Cassandra is not
the most scalable solution
terms of speed, we
allow our Memcached
to store the data for us
to grow fast, if needed.
We currently have over
100 microservices, just
like this one.
Each microservice is spread
across multiple availability
zones and across regions.
And the most critical
ones are even
spread across
multiple providers--
Amazon and Google-- to provide
ourselves the best redundancy
we can for our users.
For internal
communications, we have
developed our own discovery
system and communication.
This is done through
a peer-to-peer system,
so servers connect directly.
They do not have any
single point of failures
or any bottlenecks for traffic.
To power up all these 100-plus
microservices and Cassandra
clusters and everything
else, we currently
have over 35,000 cores
at any given time,
growing up to double the
amount in case of rush hours.
I hope you can see this is
a very large scale and such.
The thought of
changing providers
might be a crazy one, even.
Who does that, right?
But as one of the folks who
actually did a migration,
I can say, it's very easy.
It's easier than you think.
It's very interesting
because most migration talks
you'll hear are either bullion,
either this provider, or that.
A partial migration lets
you mix-and-match provider
solutions.
And you can decide to
remain split among providers
long-term.
And you can enjoy the benefit
of both worlds at the same time,
and experiment while you do so.
For example, in 2015, Amazon had
an outage that lasted 8 hours.
This was pre our GCP migration.
We wanted to spin
up our GCP cluster
sooner than what we wanted.
But sadly, we couldn't do it,
just because we weren't ready.
Our engineers work a lot of
time to make sure Waze will not
crash that day.
And I'm happy to say we didn't.
But it was very, very close.
And this was one of
the triggers for us
to actually realize we actually
need a multi-cloud solution
and not just rely
on one provider.
So Waze was acquired by Google
in 2013, as you probably know.
Now, if you're owned by a
company who provides cloud
services, it makes sense
that we'll look at it
and not just say, we'll stick
with what we have, but doesn't
mean that we'll actually
migrate to that if it
doesn't make sense.
We had that privilege
of picking ourself
what provider we want to run.
And we weren't forced
anything upon us.
It's also very hard
to choose a provider.
to choose a provider,
because there are
so many of those
and they look differently.
Right?
There is this cloud.
And even this cloud.
And how about this pretty one?
And there is even
an actual cloud.
So how do you choose one?
So why GCP?
When you choose-- migrating
to another provider--
sorry.
So when you choose to
switch to another provider,
you have to set yourselves some
key points that you want to do.
Because you have
to measure that.
And if you do not
measure that, how
do you know it's
a successful move,
or if it even makes
sense for you to do that?
In our case, when
we evaluate the GCP,
we choose that cost, resilience,
and end-user performance
is what matters to us.
So let's take a look
at each one of those.
Cost.
If you want to get
the best price for UVM
on other providers, you have
to reserve them in advance,
and figure out how many
you want to reserve.
Because all our system
uses auto scaling,
that number was never right.
We either underestimated
or overestimated.
It doesn't matter how you
look at it, we lost the money.
Not to mention that this process
was the very time-consuming.
Sadly, I did it, so I know.
We wasted days of work
every quarter just
to figure out what is that
percentage that we need to buy.
Not to mention, that
reserving an instance
means that you're
locked into that one.
Let's say you have a new
family being released--
a new CPU family--
you want to use that.
Sadly, you can't.
You're stuck for either
one year or three years.
What can you do?
Or maybe you have
redesigned your application
and now you actually don't need
those 200 nodes of Cassandra
and you actually need three.
In GCP we get that
price out of the box,
because GCP has automatic
sustained use count.
For us, it made sense that
all our expensive workloads
should move to GCP
as soon as we can,
because that will lower
our costs significantly.
Next up we have
custom machine types.
For those of you who are not
familiar with custom machine
types, they allow you to
pick any flavor you want,
take x cores and x and y
memory, and if you need,
add a few
[? localize ?] as these.
But if you don't,
don't add them.
Each one you can do
whatever you want.
At first it may not
seem that special.
But when you're dealing with
a flood of microservices,
it actually makes sense.
You have to find
that just balance
between cost and performance.
Here on the screen,
we can see an example
of a Cassandra cluster we have
moved from Amazon to Google.
That Cassandra
cluster had 6 nodes.
On the Amazon site, it was in
I2 for Excel, which did the best
price for it-- is almost 2,500.
But we actually picked that one
just because we needed the CPU.
We didn't need all
that local SSD We also
didn't need all that RAM.
But you couldn't do
anything with that.
Because that's what you get.
We used custom VMs to
exactly pick what we needed.
We needed 20 virtual CPUs,
and 30 gigabytes of memory,
and just one local
SSD, which, in Google,
that's 375 gigabytes.
As you can see, the
price difference is huge.
Now, of course we could reserve
those instances in Amazon.
But still, you can see
there is a huge difference.
If you combine both of those
materials, reserving instances
and custom VMs, we have
managed to save Waze over 20%
every year, just
because of those.
And that's a lot.
The next metric we
have was resilience.
GCP's flat network provide
us a seamless cross-region
transport.
A VM can communicate to
a VM in the same region
just as easily as it can
talk to another region.
You don't have to worry about
firewall rules, external IPs,
encryption, or so forth.
It's as simple as that.
This is something we
couldn't do in AWS,
which prevented us
from moving easily
into a multi-region solution.
And lastly, we have latency.
Google's load
balancer is globally
deployed in all these
locations, giving the best
latency and performance
for our end users.
This was a critical path for us,
because Waze currently serves
over 100 countries worldwide.
It's not just the US where
you want the best latency,
but you have to care about
those South America customers
or those APEC customers.
Everyone matters, in our case.
For example, let's
take a service
that we've migrated into GCP.
These servers basically
loads up the map
that you see on the screen.
Whenever you use Waze,
you get those images.
It's a very simple application.
It's a stand-alone one
that on the front end,
it has NGINX, on the
back end, Tomcat,
and it's being served by
Cassandra and Memcached
in order to have all
tiles cached there.
Memcached currently
has over 99% hit ratio
because we don't change
the map every second,
we change it every day.
Using the same design
we had in Amazon,
we have managed to improve
our latency by 10%.
That means 10% lower latency
for all our customers
just by moving.
We didn't do any change.
And, just like this
service, we have dozens more
that benefit this improvement.
Sorry about that.
Once we've decided that
we want to migrate,
we have set ourselves
some principles
on how we plan to migrate.
First of all, we
wanted to make sure
that we shield our developers
from this migration.
Our team shouldn't make
the developers' job
harder because it's more
efficient to run on GCP.
They should be working and not
stressful about the migration.
That's not a healthy engineer.
Next, you should always
have an escape plan.
In this case, I'm not
sure if he has one.
In case we have any
issues with the migration,
we wanted to have
a fast rollback.
This gave us more confidence in
going fast, because we always
knew there was a way back.
We never let it go.
And, lastly, we're doing
this for our users.
If we're impacting
our users just
because we want to migrate,
there's no reason to migrate.
Let's say you guys are
finishing a long day's work.
All you want to do is get
home as quickly as possible
and making sure that Waze
actually works for you.
Otherwise, you might be
stuck in a traffic jam,
and you won't get home to spend
time with your family, friends,
or just relax with
your favorite pet.
Or maybe you want a cuddly pet--
up to you-- but you
want to get home.
Next up, we decided on how
we were going to migrate.
We needed to design
how we will do this.
Because we have set
ourselves some principles
of fast rollback,
we need the solution
that we can run both
services at the same time.
We've decided to use
Amazon's and Google's managed
VPN solutions.
It made sense-- out-of-the-box
solution-- why not?
Sadly, that didn't work for us.
We quickly understood
that Amazon's VPN solution
has some faults.
It doesn't scale
as much as we need,
and when you transmit
large amount of packets,
it has also a lot
of packet loss,
both things we
couldn't tolerate.
We sat down with
Google engineers to try
and figure out what we can do.
So we have built a solution
that looks like this.
On the Amazon side, we've
purchased Direct Connect fibres
that basically go into
our clinic's data center.
There, we've
purchased a rack that
has off-the-shelf VPN
appliances, multiple of those,
of course, for redundancy.
From those VPN appliances,
we've established connection
to Google's managed
VPN solution,
because that one is scalable
and doesn't have any issues.
This allowed us to have
both providers look
like it's just one provider.
A VM can talk to a VM just
as he talks to a VM meeting
its own, its region.
And if it's in GCP,
it doesn't know.
It has another IP address, but
for him it's an internal IP.
It just works.
This later has evolved
into a managed solution
that Google is
providing customers.
And it has improved since
we've designed this.
If you guys want
to use this, you
don't need those VPN appliances.
Google's solution
just allows you
to take a fiber cable from
Amazon and from Google
and connect them.
And that's it.
That product is called
private interconnect.
So now that we have a reliable
and a low-latency connectivity,
we can start migrating
our services.
But we needed to
come up with a way
to achieve our other principles.
How do we shield those
engineers from being
frustrated because we migrate?
They shouldn't care if it's
in Amazon or in Google.
They just want to deploy
their applications.
We've done a lot of research.
And we found out
that Spinnaker, which
is an open-source application
developed by Netflix
and maintained also by
multiple other companies,
is the right choice for us.
Spinnaker supports
multi-cloud setup.
It supports both Amazon
and Google, and even
the [? server, ?]
if you want one.
It's maintained
by Google, itself,
and we even have engineers
from Google working on it here,
and Microsoft and
other companies.
As you can see here,
we have an application.
This is real production traffic.
In one page, we can
see our application
running both in
Amazon and in Google.
We don't need to worry about it.
We don't need to figure
out where it's running.
And we can also see that one
instance out of those 120
shards we have in
Amazon is misbehaving.
So we can terminate it
easily or alter scaling wheel
automatically.
We don't need to worry about it.
Spinnaker also allows us to
have automatic pipelines.
In one single pipeline,
we can upgrade
the binary and configuration
in both environments.
We don't need to worry about it.
It's just one click.
That pipeline produces,
or actually executes,
more pipelines underneath.
Each pipeline has canary testing
and fast rollback in case
there is a problem
in the canary.
That way, our developers
can deploy fast
without worrying about if
the code is stable or not.
If you want to learn more
about continuous deployment
and how we use Spinnaker in
our production traffic system
actually, I recommend you
sign up for my session
that my colleague is giving on
Friday to talk about Spinnaker.
Now, earlier I talked about
the outage Amazon had in 2015.
I'm sure most of you will
recognize the headline.
This was just last week.
They just gave me more
material for my work, I guess.
In 2015, we barely
survived that outage.
Our engineers worked very
hard to maintain ourselves.
But here, we were just fine.
Because we've implemented
those principles,
we've defined ourselves.
We have multi-cloud, and we
are not bounding ourselves
to a single provider.
So in case one goes
down, we're just
launching instances
in the next one.
And a lot of companies did
go down, but we didn't.
I want to summarize a
few things that we've
learned along the way.
I think those will
be valuable to you.
Don't look at it
as a huge migration
from multimillion company or
a multimillion user company.
Look at it on a
service-by-service basis.
You might find that you have any
stand-alone services that you
can just as easily migrate
them without worrying
about those big blocks
that have 500 dependencies
or dozens of dependencies.
And you can start saving up just
because you've moved that part.
And if you find that
you evaluate GCP
and you can't run that
service on GCP, just wait.
It might get better.
And I know because we've done
this for the past 3 years,
and we've been
constantly evaluating GCP
until the heat-- it has
reached the point where we're
saying to ourselves,
this is the right moment,
it's ready for us, let's move.
So what's next for us?
We are continuing our
migration, and we're
hoping to finish it this year.
We're also looking at
how we can actually
utilize GCP's infrastructure
for better service,
to improve our service for our
end users, and our redundancy.
And as I said earlier,
our users matter.
Eventually we're
doing it for them,
not because we want to
run on GCP or on AWS.
I want to finish
off with this image
that I found, which
reminds me of how
I feel with this migration.
Imagine you are going to the
same arcade shop every day
for the past years, playing
the same video games every day.
And then there's a new arcade
shop across the street.
Who won't want to try that?
It has newer and
different games.
So you'll enjoy that.
But that doesn't mean
you have to only use
that new shiny arcade shop.
You can use both.
What happens if there is a
power failure at the new one?
You can go back
to the other one.
You'll just think
for your company
and for your users what seems
to be the most logical thing
to do.
And go with your
heart because that's
what we did, and we feel more
confident that our service is
more redundant today and
resilient to any outage
that we'll have.
I want to thank you for
your time and for taking--
for being here.
And for learning
everything on GCP.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]